[Musique]
là
séguin
[Musique]
à quoi servent à quoi
il papa
[Applaudissements]
j'ai compris tu m'as hot wings
bonjour qu'est ce que vous voulez
d'accord pour quel motif
vous avez faim de quoi
vous aimez tous les
dit le jem le poulet à windy temps oui
j'aime le poulet
j'aime les cuisses et dupuy un peu
dit le
oui tous au dessus est la plus sensuelle
ah oui oui les frites il aime mes frites
celui ci
indique que j'aime l'esprit
hm les patates
dit je suis le même esprit
[Applaudissements]
vous dégoûter les draws mode avec le
pouls et 1,26 me kate appartenez
vous avez de bennoo
je
ne
sais quoi croyants ou non oui ouais bah
voilà la commande tes lecteurs quand tu
es
c'est
le sens de la voiture qu'ils m'ont un
peu comme un petit peu ton p'tit cul là
[Applaudissements]
s'arrête où commence quoi et où le mot
poulet en fin
d'avant-midi rideau c'est bon
tu vas pas reconnu je travaille ici là
maintenant ah oui bah j'ai ouvert un
petit je suis dans le poulet d'offrir on
écoute moi bien ta commande c'est pour
moi ces canaux
salut offert merci
n'ont reculé monsieur reculer ou qui va
celui-ci la roue vous reculez vous
reculez
vont reculer
qu'est ce que ça veut dire cette
mascarade
vous avancez là vous arrivez comme un
taureau par les cornes la
fête ça la compagnie je vous vois pas
bien
la compagnie d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as calme et moi
ta réfléchi
nantes est paralysé nantes est pas
arrivé
maintenant je vous promets je vous
entends pas
[Musique]
valéry tholy le poids là croyez-moi ça
va se terminer
mais qu'est ce qu'il veut
[Musique]
une bague est allé chez boulanger
et vous tromper d'adressé ni de bétheny
de baguettes ici si vous êtes venus ici
pour me dire des insanités vaut aussi ça
va pas aller bien
vous me dites des insanités vous êtes
anti vulgaire un personnage - ba ba ba
pour griezmann a rich man
sur la surface de réparation
h l'heure hassler qui rend dans la
surface
technique en fait moi je travaillais
avant je travaillais dans tout ce qui
est commerce international tu dois
m'acquitter shirt est conçu et droits de
l'individu
l'afutt de ma vie moi
mais je peux quand même terminé mon
histoire si ça te dérange pas quoi toi
tu en a rien à [ __ ] des gens quand tu
es tranquille tu pense qu'à manger ton
foulée toi
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de l'embouteillage
et mon coeur il ya pas un goûter a tant
manqué
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
d'éclairer comprends ce que tu veux
c'est pour moi
[Musique]
amenez quoi
pourquoi pas quant à la coupe vous
donnerai jamais
non moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ] toujours a
besoin d rien à [ __ ] de plus que toi
je ne donnerai jamais d'accord c'est
chiant non général va bien
bah y'a pas y'a plus on n'a plus rien à
laval a pas de moindre des choses vous
avez été insolente envers ma personne
vous avez fait quoi ta relation
le responsable est le responsable selon
merde
non jamais je donnerais jamais waridon
cet été
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
comment
je suis sidéré par la gentillesse des
gens
très vite les pousse vraiment à bout et
d'ailleurs ils s'amusent les mamies se
met des perruques tous avec le voit mais
juste ça les fait plaisir la vierge est
la honte complètement ont fait il en
admise dans le truc wauquiez tôt qui
portait assez vite nous emmener
quelqu'un comme ça dans un drive de fast
food qui vous parle comme ça les
réactions c'est comment deux secondes je
réalise serait rentrée dans son box là
et ça ce serait très mal passé jusqu'à
ce que je découvre que c'était un centre
bien évidemment bien sûr benjamin vous
avez vous qu'êtes vous êtes un peu soupe
au lait voici un mois extrêmement
qu'elle serait dure et deux secondes
cette bouffée son chapeau heureusement
il n'y a pas de règle chez fauchon
relativement zen calme c'était chef au
calme pour me chercher et là honnêtement
si je tombe sur quelqu'un comme lui
ouais je pense que je vais très vite
monter dans les tours vu ma copine je
pense que j'empruntais la gueule il ya
des chances mais je vais travailler vous
avez avec votre petit point
comme ça tout notre
équipe est impressionnant il peut en
tout cas s'il arrive très bien à rendre
les gens pour rien parce que bien
décrits dans les caméras cachées faut le
dire tout tout est un programme bien sûr
avons bien sûr non mais s'il faut faire
là dedans bâtir avec le libre c'est le
mewen bien sûr